[Applause]
dude
she takes one trip to the capitol and
then totally changed everything
we saw you you were one of the black
people in the
yo capitol why the blackfield should
have said they were there i didn't get
my 600.
and you know what and the black me like
i could see that i could see that why
they went there
like no one else will see i know you
guys still shouldn't have went
don't understand if it comes to the
stimulus check can you say something
about storming the capital
yeah sure it was fine that [ __ ] was
exhilarating
uh this is my my thing about the storm
the capital i might have already said
this but i'm not sure
you're doing a lot of podcasts those
people that did it are absolute [ __ ]
idiots i don't want insurrection in
america i don't want this to happen i
don't want a coup correct you know i
don't want any of that to happen correct
okay
but i also kind of hate every one of
those senators
yo it is like i i do like the fact that
they felt terrified and had to run into
their bunkers little [ __ ]
yeah that's the one thing i thought is
at least they're not trying to hurt
human beings and they're only hurting
themselves
that's high like you're going after the
lips yeah you went after the lizards
yeah you were exterminated i'm just
saying there's a little part of me
that like relishes in the fact that you
know mitch mcconnell and nancy powers
chuck schumer are all terrified and
hobbling their old
knees [ __ ] halls trying to find
safety there's a little part of me
that's excited about that what does that
say about me am i
politicians i i don't want to become
that i hate all politicians guys but
there's
guy but there's certain ones that gotta
go
and all the ones we have now are dogs
literally all of them gotta go i don't
wanna i don't wanna be that i hate all
politicians
i just sip water i'm like i ain't even
gonna i'm that guy yo but certain ones
gotta go
though right yeah like yo i'll be honest
with you
when we out of new york bro
we down there in florida at mar-a-lago
are we down in florida more longer
steve's house yeah we're on fc when we
down there in florida if we're down
there in florida it's if
you know what i mean no confirmation is
just made just yet but as
if we're down there in florida
i think one of mark's buddies said it
best bro oh no
in desantis we trust oh yeah yeah
wow my man just said people gotta die
sometimes bro yeah i texted my buddies
from back home i was like yo how's
florida you just said the santa sweet
trust that was it
everything's busted open son uh-huh run
on guys
come on guys oh they busted open and we
finally get a little thotty
bro we gonna get daddy out there in my
if we go to miami we're gonna get super
thotty out there i'm not having brunch
with a scarf on anymore
i had brunch with a scarf wrapped over
my mouth and i would take it down
yeah to eat and then put it back up
[ __ ] mortal kombat
yeah [ __ ] scorpio it was a scorpion
that [ __ ] get over here he was ready for
it zero like stay away from me
yeah but damn no
taylor not yet when we're 30 minutes in
then you can start talking about the
capital no we're gonna get back to the
capitol
my point is you like to know that the
politicians are a little bit like
on edge i want you to feel on edge the
rest of the country's feeling on it
right so the country feels anxiety the
rest of the country is like i don't know
if we're gonna be able to live next
month i don't know if my business is
gonna be done
i don't know if i'm gonna die from
corona i don't know if i'll ever get a
vaccine
i've been trying to get my parents who
are over 65 a vaccine
have you tried to get your folks a
vaccine go to texas i told you this
people were flying to florida to get the
vaccine
can you do that florida let's
non-residents get it i don't know you
just gotta go to florida and risk
getting it before the vaccine
then it takes ten days for the [ __ ] to
talk florida florida we were talking all
this [ __ ] about
these people they just want to heal the
old yeah that's all that
florida's crazy in the world they just
want to vaccinate people killing it
right now
two red states are killing it yeah two
residents but all the red states are
going yeah that's us
it's like when somebody takes christmas
my red state and it's his best it's a
group project they're in a group project
right now but that's the same [ __ ] like
when like you take credit for like
like when a black person takes credit
for like what lebron does yeah like
lebron will do something black
black excellence yeah that's our culture
somebody got to carry that torch for
white people and not a tiki torch
what do you mean don't they do that for
trump like doesn't trump speak for all
white people
no no as in like for the trump
supporters don't they be like oh that's
my people
yeah but i don't think that they take um
they take credit for the act based on
some sort of like genetic lottery
but we don't look at the iphone and go
yo we did that well because they we're
not asian but if
they if they they might go maybe they do
what you thought was steve jobs made the
iphone
yeah that's kitty though we did that
[ __ ] diddy though
we did that the first one he made in his
ride look look look i know some white
guy made this
but did they though i'm pretty sure
an asian put this [ __ ] together bro and
they killed it
yo asians keep it up bro y'all be
murdering the whole world with your
viruses
don't write a blog about me anyway so i
don't think that that's that bad a
situation like to feel
so much animosity towards these
politicians they should be on edge
that's when everybody's work performance
is the best you're worried about getting
fired all the time
yeah we ain't gonna vote but we'll kill
you
that's kind of cool yo hey you can get
overthrown at any moment now you better
get together let me ask you a question
okay if and
again i don't want to harp on this more
but i'm just so infuriated by
just the job that's been done right
if you worked at a like a packaging
plant right
and your job was to make sure that there
are enough boxes
boxes to put the packages in right okay
you get told by your boss
in eight months we're probably gonna
have a lot of packages to send
right make sure that there are enough
boxes
for all those packages you have eight
months to prepare for that moment
okay and you go i got this that's my job
it's my responsibility
to prepare for this yeah you don't worry
about anything i'll take care of it
exactly and you go on tv every single
day and you're like i'm in control of
this i take responsibility i take
accountability if you said that every
single day for eight months
and then eight months came around and
you didn't get any more boxes to put
those packages in
i [ __ ] up would you get fired at least
bare minimum fire
at least politics is the only job
where you could [ __ ] up over and over
and over again
and not lose your job you give yourself
a raise
you can give yourself a raise it's
unbelievable
you know i'm just i'm looking at cuomo
going on tv
every single day yapping his stupid fat
[ __ ] mug
talking about what he's gonna do i
really in the beginning i kind of liked
him because i liked it a little like
alpha italian energy yeah i was like
yeah you want to whip the country into
shape i need a guy who's going to
[ __ ]
gabba ghoul every once in a while it's
going to be fun and the fact that he's
been
yapping for eight months about
accountability this that the other
i think we got more corona than any
other place in the country not that
more than florida la max dinner la's
maybe la's top
the other [ __ ] cuck out there in
florida [ __ ] that right
single single guy 50 no kids
hanging out in pelosi's district a
little bit gavin oh
[ __ ] the point is it drives me [ __ ]
crazy pelosi's district of san francisco
for all yeah
that is what it is we will explain a
little bit point is
i'm infuriated by these guys that have
acted as if they're somewhat
presidential during this time
for faking to care about the people and
doing nothing in the eight months that
they had the opportunity to prepare for
this second wave
that they told us about when you have
these people down south
florida uh who's uh uh who's the
governor of uh is it's
perry or something like that of uh texas
i can't remember wheelchair [ __ ]
yeah it doesn't matter point is you have
you have desantis
you have perry you have these guys greg
abbott greg
abbott abbott right so desantis and
abbott
right nobody's talking about them as
potential
presidential nominees right nobody's
even entering them in the discussion
yet the entire country who can
afford to do it and it's not everybody
who can't afford is a luxury to be able
to move in any time in your life
especially during pandemic but the
entire country that can move
is moving to those states the people in
those states are happy
the rest of the country the can is
gravitating to other states
how the [ __ ] are we considering newsom
and cuomo
where people are fleeing their [ __ ]
states and everybody in the states
are are absolutely furious how are we
even considering them as presidential
using your box analogy i [ __ ] up all
the boxes and you're like you know what
you might get promoted
that's what we're talking about
unbelievable that's potential forma won
an emmy
for what for his uh about chris cuomo
no andrew chromo andrew cuomo received
international emmy from masterful covid
19 briefing
that's not even an abortion no he
deserves it he deserves it
because if you could give a masterful
briefing while doing absolutely nothing
and convince people that you were doing
something you deserve an enemy that's
true that guy deserves it that's
that's acting it's right that's
everybody's getting an emmy i don't want
an emmy anymore hey emmy committee
i don't want it al wants his
[ __ ] but that's just politics though i
think we just learned that like the name
of the game is just whoever can make
people feel the comfiest even if you're
doing nothing
yo you know i feel comfy florida texas
i'm just saying i want to eat i'm
starting to get
furious have you heard your friends back
in texas i'm
a shout out to like what has happened
with like politics and everything now i
learned some new words i didn't know
what a coup was and [ __ ]
that's a good point
you